chemistry is beautiful
the endless variety of snowflakes
astounding mechanics of our cells mega
molecules the rainbow of fluorescent
proteins it is a work of art it's also a
long way from the usual view of
chemistry a world of oil spills huge
chemical plants and endless colorless
solutions but the beauty is there if you
know where to look drop of a colorless
solution into another colorless solution
turns a brilliant pink as a child it's
like magic that you understand the magic
the beauty of chemistry is in part in
the shapes of the molecules and
understanding the architecture of the of
the molecules and one of them is
hemoglobin is fantastic molecule if you
watch this molecule no one can be other
than amazed if they say for the first
time in chemistry this beauty doesn't
come out of the mind of a great artist
its inherent in nature a large part of
what chemists do is to try to unravel
this beauty to look at the mechanisms
driving the endlessly complicated world
around us
the beauty of chemistry is that if you
can find out what is going on in one
place and find a repeatable pattern you
can predict what will happen somewhere
else
the beguiling ly simple equations that
chemists create to describe their
observations often hold extraordinary
power for the scientists you can find
beauty in equations right you've the
same you know beauty is a sort of
cathartic response within you so let's
start with the Schrodinger equation
which I consider to be gorgeous red -
fear of these papers that establish the
Schrodinger equation - and I was
she started from classical mechanics and
with very sort of a sleight of hand
he ended up in a pager too with the
Schrodinger equation which underpins
everything about the electronic
structure of it was just breathtaking
chemistry there's not only a beauty of
simplicity but often there's a kind of
symmetry and sometimes you you can
recognize that you're wrong because it
doesn't feel right you know it feels
asymmetrical in some sense the equations
that Schrodinger Kearn Marcus and
hundreds of others developed describe
the nuts and bolts of the world around
us it's like taking the back off that
perfect Swiss watch and seeing the
endless cogs while for the scientist the
mechanism might be beautiful even if the
watch face isn't the periodic table for
me is one of the most beautiful things
around it underpins the whole of
chemistry for me we you that it's the
coat hanger on which we hang our
understanding of it
it explains therefore the whole of life
as well
like an artist endlessly searching for
beauty and truth in their work the dream
of finding that really beautiful idea is
still what keeps scientists up late at
night all around the world
I wrote supervisor and paper and derived
a certain equation so but it was messy
ugly messy and I found just by changing
the order everything became simple it's
just like popping out a simple result
came out and that's the result that's
used today
that was maybe the most exciting thing
in my scientific life it was really a
Eureka I've started writing this
equation on on napkins I leave it in a
restaurant and my wife is worried that
I'm going to become a what do you call
it someone who puts things on a wall but
yes equations are beautiful even when
ideas are beautiful enough to transform
scientists into graffiti artists and
Nobel laureates they're still just ideas
they exist in the realm of ancient Greek
philosophers and their modern-day
equivalent theoretical physicists
chemists deal in the real and the
tangible they need a way to test these
elegant daydreams in short they need
experiments and to a chemist there are
ugly experiments and there are most
certainly beautiful experiments you have
an idea and it works
and it works better than you expected
not only Bettany's but in the totally
unexpected way and you realize that
nature's a lot cleverer than you are
Harry kroto and Robert Cole were trying
to look at the formation of matter in
and around stars aided by a brilliant
bit of apparatus designed by Richard
Smalley they not only produced but
identified and purified a new sort of
carbon we did this experiment to
simulate the conditions in a star you
know what uses that I mean what sort
uses that to Cameron and then we
discover this beautiful molecule c60
which is related to architecture they
produce something that was just
beautiful through and through the
experiment was beautifully simple but
told you so much
the mathematical elegance of the
structure spoke volumes
and yet the steroid structure of c60 had
a symmetry and beauty even the untutored
I could appreciate chemistry
it's analogous I think to an
impressionist ik impressionistic
painting is a marvelous thing but you
know if you stand too close to
oppression istic painting it's
completely meaningless dabs of paint you
stand too far away it's equally
meaningless blur at the right distance
is uncanny it's fabulously you know you
wonder how the artists created this -
dabs of P you know what you see in it as
chemists is exactly like that
you
music